with more gatherings happening right now
during the holidays more people are
looking to get tested today i spoke to
an official here at the southern nevada
health district and they tell me they
are trying to get you your results as
fast as they can as omicron concerns
linger more people are trying to make
sure they don't spread the virus last
week the health district conducted 8 000
tests at just its sites that's up 3 000
tests from the week before after getting
tested some people are getting messages
like this stating results could take
seven days but the health district told
me they are turning results in about 48
hours still many testing companies are
noticing the increase amanda ellis from
e-7 testing clinic says they are also
seeing more people there's definitely at
least a 50 increase that we've seen
recently with demand for pcr testing
with the holidays and also with the
variant happening there are a lot of
people that want to make sure that
they're tested for small gatherings she
says their pcr testing results can be
done in about an hour which is why so
many people flying out of the country
are going to them ella says with the
holiday long holiday weekend that is she
expects even more people to get tested
this weekend and even next week
reporting outside the health district
joe muller live local now